- [Voiceover] This program is presented by
University of California television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to a Conversation
with History, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest is George
Packer, his new book is
The Unwinding, an Inner
History of the New America.
George, welcome to Berkeley.
- It's great to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Down in Stanford, the rival.
I grew up on campus, my parents
were both faculty members,
and I lived 18 years in
that idyllic place before
leaving for good when I
graduated from high school.
- And where were you educated?
- I went to Yale, I got
a B.A., went off to the
Peace Corps in West Africa,
a little tiny village,
and that was the end
of my formal education.
- And your mother was a professor
of creative writing at Stanford.
- Yes, she was a short
story writer, she still is.
She actually just published
her latest book at age 87.
And she taught in the english department
and ran the creative
writing program for a while.
My father was in the law school,
and then became an administrator.
He was the vice provost just in time
for the revolution of '67, '68.
So I grew up in a family of writers
and of politically-minded people.
- You have an earlier book
which I would like to talk about
because it's called Blood of the Liberals,
it was published in 2000,
and it's a book about
your coming to terms with
the political tradition
that your family was a part of,
both your grandfather was
an important progressive
congressman from Alabama, and your father
was a distinguished liberal lawyer.
Talk a little about that,
because it was important for you
to shape your identity, and
it's an elaborate process,
looking back at the tradition
that they were a part of.
- Yeah, my mother's
father, George Huddleston,
was a Congressman from
Birmingham, Alabama,
from Wilson to Roosevelt.
And he came out of an
old tradition of populism
that goes back to
Jefferson, and forward to
William Jennings Bryan
and Robert LeFollett.
And his career is a reminder
that back in the teens
and 20s and 30s, there were real radicals
at the highest levels of
government, in Congress.
And he was one of them, but his radicalism
was just as suspicious
of Roosevelt's new deal
as it was of J.P. Morgan and the trusts.
So he ended up losing out
to a new dealer in 1936.
So that is one strain of
liberalism in this country.
It's very old, it flourished in
the South and in the Midwest.
There's another strain which
is more urban and more modern,
which my father represented.
He was Jewish, he grew
up in the northeast,
was one of the Jews to
survive the barriers
and get into Yale in spite of its quotas.
He fought in World War II, and then he was
a legal scholar who ran
afoul of Herbert Hoover
and the witch hunters of the
50s because he wrote a book
about Alger Hiss and other ex-communists,
and other communists who
were outed by ex-communists.
His book didn't find his
innocent, but it was enough of
a study of what went wrong
in the pursuit of the
communists of that period
that it sort of branded him
a lefty, he was not, he was a liberal.
My family is full of liberals,
who are sort of the most vulnerable
political species in our country.
And my father's career came
up against a different kind of
radicalism in the 60s, when he
was a Stanford Administrator
during the student revolution,
and that was kind of
the end of his career and
ultimately he fell ill with
a stroke, and that was
the end of his life, too.
So the book, Blood of the
Liberals looks at these
past generations to try to
understand, how did liberalism
flourish and fail during the 20th century.
So by the time I was an adult,
it hardly even seemed to have
a pulse as a vibrant political
movement in this country.
- And your family was very
much influenced by the events
at Stanford and the protests
against the Vietnam War
in the sense that Stanford
was confronted by the new
radicalism that was emerging
in protest to the war.
- Yeah, my father was a, he
was a believer in procedure.
He was a scholar of criminal
law, he believed in argument.
And what he found was, the
students who he was running
up against as an administrator
seemed to want to
dispense with reason
all together, which they
in some cases regarded
as like a tool of power.
It was kinda the beginning
of post-modern critique of
the Enlightenment, and of
reason on the part of the Left.
And for my father, this was abhorrent.
He saw in their appeals
to feeling something
frighteningly like some of
the ideologies of Europe
that brought the continent
into a conflagration.
So he was, he saw sit-ins as
being coercive, and against
the tradition of academic
and intellectual freedom.
He was that kind of a
liberal, an ACLU liberal,
a free speech liberal, but
not a believer in overthrowing
established institutions,
he was a reformed liberal.
And that kind of liberal
died in the 60s and 70s,
and in a sense we've been waiting
for its revival ever since.
- You write, you say I was
trying to sift through the ruins
of liberalism to seek and
choose a new mode of politics,
rather than live out
the one I was born to.
So this...
Period that you were
coming to your maturity,
really was a time in which
the world was coming apart,
politically and so on.
- I had a strong sense as a child even
that the world was coming apart and that
the ideals and creed of my forefathers
was not strong enough to withstand it.
When I was eight years
old, I was keenly aware
of the assassinations of King and Kennedy,
the protests here at
Berkeley, Stanford, Columbia.
The Vietnam War, the body counts.
Drugs and the Manson killings, and it just
seemed like society was coming apart.
And my father's faith in
reason, I just had on an
elemental level a sense that
it didn't stand a chance.
Without thinking it through in those terms
'cause I was only eight, I just feared
for the fragile world
that I had been born into,
that my parents had created
kind of as a shelter,
as a protection for me and for my sister,
it just didn't seem able to
stand up to what seemed like
a world going mad.
- You say in addition, my
generation has no Jefferson
and no New Deal to set our compass by.
- Right.
And I think we've been, my
whole adult life, which,
if you look at 18 as the beginning of it,
has coincided with the
rise of conservative power
in Washington, and business
power across the country.
I've been waiting for,
looking for, thinking about,
how you could build a new
reformed liberal politics
on the bones of the old, of the
period from the progressives
through the New Deal, into
the post-war social contract.
Which, I wasn't alive then
so I'm probably prone to
romanticizing and to
missing out on something,
obviously there was massive injustice
committed against black Americans,
women had no opportunities,
gay Americans were non-people.
But it was a social order that
had the tools of self-correction.
The institutions were healthy
enough that they could
fix what was wrong, and
they did, they began to.
I've seen those efforts at reform and at
creating more equal
opportunity rather than less,
come up against the new power,
which is not government, it's business.
And I've been waiting for
a politician or a politics
to come up with a new
version, 'cause it never dies
completely, of what Jefferson and the
Progressives and Roosevelt created.
We haven't seen it.
I thought maybe in 2008 Barack
Obama was going to be that
politician, but I think he was up against
forces that were stronger than he is.
- After your undergraduate work,
you went on an odyssey, really.
Let's talk a little about
that, because you end up
as a writer, but before you
did that, you essentially
were in the Peace Corps, you
worked in a homeless shelter --
- Worked in construction for a few years.
- [Harry] Construction.
- [George] Yeah.
- And what did you learn
from that experience?
Clearly you learned to be
an observer at some point
of these different worlds
that were around you.
- I think a key experience for me was
living in a little village
in Togo in West Africa.
Totally on my own, no American near me.
And trying to survive,
because I did not have
the inner resources that
it took to live in that
kind of alien environment,
in that kind of isolation.
I was 22, all my life I had been
at one University or another.
I'd been a good student, I had done well,
I'd been rewarded, and suddenly there was
nothing like that to sustain me.
And I guess I felt, to
survive I'm gonna have to
make connections to the
people in this village.
And I did learn a lot about
how to listen to people
from very different
backgrounds and experiences.
I was just intensely interested in them.
And never stopped asking them questions.
And it was partly because that
was the only companionship
I had, and partly 'cause it
seemed like my life had been
too limited, it was
necessary to kind of break it
in order to find out what
life was really about.
It was sort of like someone from an
earlier generation maybe joining the army,
or just going and
traveling around the world.
And it damn near killed me,
but it was an incredible,
changing experience, and I think it was
the beginning of my becoming a writer.
Learning to observe, learning
to in a sense suppress
my own inner reaction
enough that I could render
the visible world and the people around me
vividly and concretely, which
is what writers have to do.
- And when you were at
the homeless shelter,
you talk about going home and doing notes,
writing up what had happened.
Did that actually start in
Africa, were you doing it then,
or when did, because
clearly, as we'll talk about
in your new book, you really
have an enormous talent
for observing and then taking down
what you're observing and
what people are saying.
- You know, I kept a journal
in Togo, but when I went
back to it in order to write
a book, 'cause my first book,
The Village of Waiting, is
about those years in Africa,
it was useless, it was just
a record of my feelings,
and it turned out that my feelings
were not very interesting in retrospect.
I remembered them, I knew what they were.
But I also wrote lots of letters,
and that was back when
letters were still written.
This was such a different
time, 1982, three, four, that
to make a phone call home I
needed weeks of preparation,
letters took six weeks to arrive,
of course there was no internet,
there were no cell phones.
So that made the
isolation pretty complete,
but it also meant I had to
pour a lot into the letters
just to convey to people
at home what I was doing.
So I gathered up those letters
when I set out to write
The Village of Waiting, and
they were a huge help in
reconstructing scenes,
characters, dialog, description.
And those are the building
blocks of narrative.
- You say in this book that liberals
learn to adjust to reality, and then
you also talk about the power of reason.
What's striking about this book
is, you go visit your aunt,
and she's become an
evangelical, and you really can
distance yourself, be objective,
but paint a portrait of
evangelicals, and even
wind up comparing them to
the socialist, which you
had been in the interim.
- Part of a group of socialists.
- So writing, in a way,
has allowed you to use
the characteristics of a
liberal, in a way, is that fair?
Although you can't be
a liberal in politics.
- I think, I wouldn't go quite that far.
I mean obviously there are
great conservative writers,
there are great liberal writers,
there are bad liberal writers.
I would say, to write
well, it helps to have
some framework for understanding life and
some set of ideals and values,
but it also helps to be able to set them
aside long enough to pay attention.
And to take in things
that are going to run
a counter to your idea of
the way the world should be.
Because otherwise you're
constantly eliding and erasing
what you're seeing,
and you're manipulating
your portraits of people
into stock figures,
and that's just bad
prose, that's bad writing.
I think some instinct has always told me,
whatever you may think about the world,
the world is gonna be a far
more interesting and complicated
place, and you'll get
more out of it as a writer
if you just stay alert and pay attention,
and don't try to make it
conform to your expectations.
Otherwise, among other
things it'll be boring.
So all of this was me learning to write,
and the model was Orwell,
I was reading Orwell
all the time in my 20s, and he
was like my graduate program.
And my idea of a writer
was someone who wrote
autobiographically, like
Orwell in his essays and in
Down and Out in Paris and
London, Homage to Catalonia,
I didn't have a notion
of being a journalist.
Of going out and interviewing
people and recording
observations that didn't
start with my own life.
So my first few books
were autobiographical,
my first articles for
magazines were essays.
And it was only like, at
40, when I moved to New York
and began writing for The New
Yorker and The New York Times
Magazine that I really
became a journalist.
But the tools were already
there, they were the same tools.
- And what, I like to ask my guests,
what are the skills and
temperament involved in
what they do, you really helped
us understand the skills,
what about the temperament
of being a writer?
- I have, I think a pretty
passionate attachment to certain
ideas which really are political ideas,
I'm a political writer pretty
much down to the marrow.
Which are a dislike of unfairness,
I'm speaking basically
here, I'm talking about
kinda stuff that starts on the playground.
A sympathy for the underdog.
An interest in what seems
different and alien.
And a belief that underneath it,
we're actually not that different.
Because everywhere I've
gone, from Togo, to Burma,
to Baghdad, I've found it
easy to talk to people,
and easy to get them to
tell me their stories,
and their stories are
easily understandable
as the aspirations of
people like the people
that I grew up with,
or people that I know.
So I guess I'm a
universalist in that sense,
and that's not quite a temperament,
but it is a sort of approach to life.
I believe that...
Above or beneath the
differences in language
and in experience, I can understand you
if I want to, and if I try hard enough.
And that means really
empathizing, not pretending,
because people immediately
pick up insincerity
in the intimate bond that's established
between a journalist and a subject.
It has to be a real desire to know you,
and I think I have a talent for
getting people to talk to me
and for getting to know them,
and I think it's because
they sense that I mean it.
- And what is your work process like?
We'll talk about the book in a minute but
you follow four main characters
at different levels of
society throughout the book.
So it's talking with and identifying them,
talking with them, winning their trust,
recording what they're saying,
but you're suggesting also
seeing in a way how they
fit into a bigger picture.
- Right, well that happens
later, I don't think I'm
thinking about how am
I gonna use this story,
what am I looking for,
it's much more intuitive
and spontaneous, it's in the moment.
We could talk about the
characters in the book
as individuals, but in
general, in each case
I just found myself wanting
to hang out with them,
wanting to be admitted
into their world because
they all live in interesting worlds.
And I intuited that those worlds
were part of a larger story
and that if I spent enough
time with them and won
their trust and got to hear
their story, and see it,
and follow them around
as they live their life,
it would be connected to a larger picture
that was the picture of The Unwinding.
I didn't know exactly
what I was looking for at
the beginning, and that's
usually how I work.
I might go, for example to post-war Iraq,
post-invasion Iraq, or to Lagos, Nigeria
with a general idea of
I'm gonna write about
the reconstruction, or I'm
gonna write about the mega city.
But who I talk to and where
those conversations lead
and what picture builds,
that's something I have to
learn as I go, and that's
the excitement of the work.
It's always a process of
revelation, I never know
what I'm going to say until
I've finished talking to people.
- The end of the book,
this first book that we're
talking about, you come to
certain conclusions about
where society is, and I
wanna bring that up because
it struck me as being a kind
of prologue to The Unwinding,
and there were several characteristics
you identified of the times.
'The main force of our lives is'
'the overwhelming force of un-reason'.
So reason has moved away from center stage
in the world you're looking at.
'There is a lack of a vision, and moral'
'and intellectual energy
such vision confers'
we're talking just generally
now about American society,
the collapse of all of the structures.
You were identifying them in
this book in the year 2000.
And then the kind of
de-legitimizing of what you call
the collective self-betterment,
that people don't believe
in reason, and they don't
believe through reason
that government can solve problems.
Just comment on that, I found
it, not having read the book
until after I read The
Unwounding, I really found it
a very compelling
introduction to The Unwinding.
- It's interesting to hear
those things quoted back
because that was what I
wrote 10 or 15 years ago,
and that was the state of mind I was in,
mainly through excavating the past,
my own past, my family's past.
Going back to this man I never
met who I was named after,
my maternal grandfather,
George Huddleston.
I think I would put it a
little differently today,
and I would approach it
a little differently.
What I didn't quite see was how...
The 60s was more of a
prologue than the main event.
And how so much of the era we live in now,
some of it was prepared
for during that time
but I think most of it came later.
And if anything, it's a kind of return to
the period my grandfather came out of,
the period of the robber
barons and of populism.
I mean, what is Occupy
Wall Street but a kind of
resurgence of populist politics?
What is Dodd-Frank but an
effort to re-create some
regulation of the financial
system that was undone.
So I think the 60s no longer seems
like this signal period to me.
And when I set out to write The Unwinding,
it came out of events that happened
after Blood of the Liberals was written.
Starting with the Iraq
war, which I covered for
The New Yorker and wrote a
book out, The Assassin's Gate.
And what I saw there was
a failure of not just
individual American leaders,
but American institutions.
Ones that I'd probably had
faith in without even knowing
I did, such as the military,
the intelligence system,
the media, and Congress
and the executives.
So I began to wonder, when
did that failure begin?
Has it been happening for a
long time, and we never noticed
until we tried to do
something that required
all of our talents and
energies and we simply
didn't have it in us to
do it, to rebuild Iraq.
And then I came back from
that war to cover the 2008
election, and suddenly every institution
in the country seemed to be collapsing.
The Wall Street investment banks,
lenders like Country
Wide, Washington Mutual.
General Motors, Chrysler, my
god, just the core pillars
of our economic life were falling apart.
And out of it came Barack Obama,
who seemed like the first
truly new and promising
national figure in a really long time.
That story, which obviously
builds on the history in
Blood of the Liberals, is a new story,
it's the story of my generation.
And I wanted to write an
account of this past generation
where the failure of these
institutions, and essentially of
the deal that held the country together,
which is basically the social contract.
Where that fell apart,
and how that fell apart,
so I needed to find a new
form for storytelling,
which is very different
from Blood of the Liberals.
No longer autobiographical, there is no
first person anywhere in The Unwinding.
It is all told through the
stories of my characters.
That was a real departure for
me, but it seemed necessary
to get my arms around as big a subject as
what has happened in America
in the last 30 years,
and to paint a portrait of
where the country is today.
- So you...
You start working on this
say in 2008, approximately,
and you then set about creating profiles.
Stories that people tell you or that
you research, and we'll talk about it.
So how does this
structure come into being?
We should explain to people
who've not read the book,
you have let's say four
main characters who are
people in different walks of life,
and you're looking at
what happens to them.
- It's a chronological
story, each of them is
of a certain cohort,
born into the 50s or 60s,
coming of age in the 70s and 80s.
And then living out
their lives and careers
in this period of real destabilization,
where things are coming apart.
One of them is Dean Price, who
is an entrepreneur in rural
North Carolina, in the bible
belt, very conservative area.
But out of this conservative background,
and he's a Reagan Republican
growing up but he sort of
latches onto alternative
energy and bio diesel fuel
as the way to revive all
the poverty and to revive
the troubles in the
countryside that he grew up in.
Tammy Thomas is a black
woman in Youngstown, Ohio,
who rose up amid the
de-industrialization of the rust belt,
the collapse of the steel
industry, and she survives and
raises her three kids by
latching onto one of the few
good blue collar jobs left
in an auto parts factory.
Jeff Connaughton is an
ambitious young guy from Alabama
who latches onto Joe Biden
as his ticket to power
and to idealism, and then
becomes disillusioned
with Biden, and becomes a lobbyist.
So the three of them are in
different parts of the country
and different, some are more
successful, some are not,
there is a kind of winners
and losers dichotomy.
The fourth is Peter Thiel,
who becomes a Silicon Valley
billionaire and a libertarian
with a sort of a vision of
a need for radical
technological change in order to
pull the country out
of economic stagnation.
And there's a fifth character
who isn't a person, it's Tampa.
Ground Zero of the housing
bust, and of all the trouble
in the way people got into
debt and got into bigger houses
than they could afford, and
then when it all went south,
the financial crisis was the result.
So five parts of the
country, five characters,
we follow them moving back
and forth between them as
their stories unfold from
the late 70s to the present.
That's a big package of
stories to tell anyway,
but I also wanted to tell
the stories of the most
influential people of the
same period, 'cause you can't
write about America today without
writing about celebrities,
and without looking at
the role of the elites.
From politics there's Newt
Gingrich, from entertainment
there's Oprah Winfrey, from
business there's Sam Walton.
From finance there's Robert Rubin,
from government there's Colin Powell.
From sort of food culture there's
Berkeley's own Alice Waters.
So I had this tremendous
amount of reporting
and research and stories,
I didn't have a structure.
And this is an unusual thing for me,
I usually have a structure early on
so I know where things go.
This all had to come together really fast.
When I began to write at
the beginning of 2012.
The structure...
Had actually come to me earlier.
But I forgot, or I discarded it,
I didn't think it could work,
and my wife reminded me.
You had an idea, it was to
do a kind of experimental
non-fiction book along the
lines of the Dos Passos trilogy
USA, where you would combine
ordinary people and the famous,
the centers of power and
obscure backwaters, and even
a kind of mish-mash of
quotes and news stories
at different moments to give a sense of
what the collective mind was like
at individual years along the way.
I gave that a try, not
knowing if it was gonna work,
it seemed like a juggling
act, but that became the form
to tell all these stories,
to hold them together
through the writing of The Unwinding.
- The only thing that I
would add to what you said,
and you know your book
better than I do, is that
in Tampa you follow a number
of secondary characters,
a journalist, a lawyer, a
woman who attends hearings
and discovers --
- In foreclosure courts, yeah.
- Who discovers the corruption.
So let's talk about the
four main characters.
Is there something that you found
that told you about what
was going on in the country
that was common to all of
them, which ones were winners,
which one were losers, but they
all seemed to have a kind of
a sense of hope, resiliency,
determination, it's just
they're differently placed
in the way they can succeed.
- That's a good way to put it.
Each of them keeps running
up against setbacks,
obstacles, dramatic changes of course.
They have to remake themselves
as the country goes through
upheavals, and I think that's
part of what allows this
disparate batch of stories
to cohere into a narrative.
There's some suspense,
what's gonna happen next with
Jeff Connaughton after he
quits working for Joe Biden.
How will Tammy Thomas
survive once her job at
the auto parts factory
gets sent to Mexico?
Will Dean Price keep pursuing
his almost religious vision of
biodiesel as the cure for what
ails the Carolina Piedmont
after his partnership
collapses and he goes bankrupt?
So their lives are interesting,
and they're surprising.
There's lots of unexpected turns.
I think what all of them are
contending with is a period,
which gives the book its title,
in which structures that
used to support these
kinds of aspirations
have begun to disappear.
And people feel more and more
that they're on their own
and have to improvise, and
figure it out for themselves.
Dean Price, who is a
son of the bible belt,
his family had been in
tobacco farming forever,
his father was a fire
and brimstone preacher.
He wanted to be a successful entrepreneur,
kind of rebelled against his father's
darker and more constrained vision.
Dean Price had no organization
to support his ambitions.
There was no business association.
No local newspaper, no trade
union, no political party.
What he's got is his own
dreams, some old books like
Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill,
who was a kind of how to
succeed in business writer
from the early 20th
century, and the internet,
where Dean finds out about things
like peak oil, and bio diesel.
And he's kind of improvising
and pulling it all together
in a very idiosyncratic
way, and inevitably screws
some of it up or gets some of it wrong,
or makes mistakes or
doesn't quite know what
he's doing, but keeps persisting at it.
So it's this resilience in the
face of dissolving structures
that is the drama of their
lives, and it is the thing
that unites all of the
characters in the book.
- And they all are learners,
I mean, in other words they
try something, it may fail,
they pick up the pieces,
and when given the opportunity,
they move to a new level.
They may end up with
disappointment, but the frustration
doesn't lead them to stop
in their quest, basically.
- And I think for different
reasons in difference cases.
In Dean Price's case, if he
were to lose faith in his quest
for redemption in rural North
Carolina through biofuels,
he would kinda lose faith in America.
It would tell him that a lonely man
with a dream no longer could make it.
And I think he did almost give up
a few times when he went bankrupt.
For Tammy Thomas, it was more a
sense that people counted on her.
Her children, her family, her community.
She's very much connected
to Youngstown as the city is
entering a death spiral
after the steel mills close.
I mean, my god, 50 thousand jobs lost
in a rather small section of
the Mahoning River Valley.
It's as if New York City
lost half a million jobs.
So it was an economic cataclysm.
It was happening all over the rust belt,
so there are many Tammy
Thomas' around the country.
She kept going because as
she said over and over,
I did what I was supposed to do.
She is not someone driven
by a grandiose dream
of achievement and
becoming a national figure
or an entrepreneur or anything like that,
she did what she was supposed to do.
Which stands in such contrast to
the culture of celebrity
that we live with.
Where you don't do what
you're supposed to do,
in fact, you win by doing what
you're not supposed to do.
You break things, you break
the rules, you cut corners,
and that's the story of many of the
celebrities in the book, including Jay-Z.
- Let's talk about the
celebrities in a minute.
I just wanna make a point about,
it comes out in Tammy, which is the,
she is, through her grandmother she gets
to live in a mansion by a former...
- A steel baron.
And what comes out is the
extent to which the barons
of the city.
- Of Youngstown.
- Of Youngstown did not
realize what was happening
as the place collapsed.
They had kept other businesses out,
but then they didn't kinda understand.
But she then becomes an
organizer and is learning
by being part of a community organization,
that takes about mapping
the city to see where the,
and so through that she
gets a larger vision
of what's going on in the city.
- Yeah, I mean here she is, a little girl.
Her mother was a heroin addict,
so rather than taking care
of Tammy, Tammy really had
to take care of her mother.
She told me this story of how
her mother would smoke in bed,
and when Tammy was a very
little girl, she would try to
keep herself awake so that
after her mother fell asleep
she could take the cigarette
out of her hands and
put it out, which is a
little detail that gives you
a big picture of what
her childhood was like.
She was raised by her great
grandmother, who worked in
white peoples' homes,
rich white peoples' homes,
and at one point when her
longest standing boss,
the widow of a steel baron,
died, and the house was
in escrow, the estate
was sort of undecided,
Tammy and her great
grandmother and her mother
went to live in this giant
old mansion on the north side
of Youngstown where the rich people lived.
And it was this magical
year in Tammy's life,
and then it ended, and she had
to return to the east side.
Which was on the verge
of falling apart when,
a few years later, the bills close.
But Youngstown's a story
of a one industry city
controlled by a handful of
families, who when they sold out
to the multi-national steel
companies, or at least to the
steel companies headquartered
outside Youngstown,
that was the death sentence.
No one any longer had a stake
in the survival of Youngstown.
And when Youngstown Sheet and
Tube, which was the largest,
locally owned mill in
Youngstown, when it was sold to
Lykes Corporation of New Orleans and then
10 years later, in a vote of the board
that happened at the Pittsburgh airport.
People flew in, they didn't
even go to Youngstown
to take the vote, they went to Pittsburgh.
And voted to close the Campbell Works,
which was the biggest part
of Youngstown Sheet and Tube,
five thousand people lost their
jobs, it was the beginning
of the death of
Youngstown, and it happened
almost without anyone in a
position of power noticing.
Suddenly this whole way of
life ended, and Tammy had to
grow up and raise her own
children in the debris,
in the ruins of this old industrial city.
And as you say, once her job
disappeared, years later,
and it was sent overseas,
she had to remake herself.
It was a matter of
survival, and she became
a community organizer, and it was like
seeing the city for the first time.
What she had taken for granted
while she was surviving
suddenly struck her with full force,
some injustice had happened here.
It angered her, she kept
using the word frustrated
while we drove around her
old haunts of the east side.
And that told me she hadn't given up.
It still, she had some
fight, and she was not
willing to let go of
Youngstown, and that spirit
remade her as a community organizer.
- Before we talk about the celebrities,
because there you're creating
another kind of mosaic
that's quite fascinating and
disturbing at the same time.
- Cannot --
- Connaughton.
- Jeff Connaughton.
- Yeah.
- Was an idealist who rose
in American politics on the
coattails of Biden, who he
became very disappointed in.
But in the end he becomes a lobbyist.
And it's quite extraordinary
because there's a period
from 2000 to 2010 when what a lobbyist is
and what a public servant is changes.
So we move from not selling out,
to I think he says cashing in.
- Yeah, suddenly, there had
been a kind of unseemliness
to going from Capital Hill
to the big lobbying firms.
Like, you did it, lot of people did it,
but it was slightly unseemly,
to being what everyone did.
I mean, astonishing numbers
of aides on Capital Hill,
fully half of retired
or defeated senators,
same number of congressmen,
end up in lobbying.
It's the obvious way to
make money in Washington
once you've been on the inside.
Jeff Connaughton followed
suit and got very rich at it.
Because his firm, Quinn
Gillespie, had connections
to both the democrats and republicans.
- It was bipartisan.
- It was bipartisan, they couldn't lose.
They used to say, we're not of
the democratic or republican
party, we're with the green party.
Meaning, we're about making
money, and whoever wins,
Bush, Gore, kind of didn't
matter all that much to
Quinn Gillespie because
they were gonna do well
no matter what, and Jeff was the
third wheel and did very well himself.
But he also became a
creature of that period.
He put his money into some
unwise real estate investments
in Costa Rica, as he said
to me, he got greedy.
He's a very honest, candid
guy, and ended up losing
a lot of his wealth in the
financial collapse of 2008.
And that partly, and I think also
just a sense of self-respect.
We were talking about
what kept them going.
With Dean it was a dream, a vision.
With Tammy it was survival and her
attachment to the people around her.
But Jeff Connaughton I
think it was a need to
look at himself in the
mirror, and to be able to.
He went back into government
as the Chief of Staff
of the guy who took
Biden's seat when Biden
became vice president, Ted Kaufman.
And Kaufman and Connaughton did something
kind of extraordinary in Washington.
They decided, they were only
gonna be there for two years,
they weren't worried about reelection,
they were gonna take on Wall Street.
And Connaughton came back
into government and was
sort of astonished to see
it, even though he'd been
a lobbyist all this time,
he hadn't seen what lobbying
had done to Washington,
how money drove so much of
what happens on Capital Hill, and how
the public voice is hardly heard at all.
So they went after the
big banks, they tried to
break them up, to
reinstate Glass-Steagall,
to prosecute the individual executives who
might have been committing crimes of fraud
that led to the financial crisis.
We know how that story turned
out, but for Connaughton
it was kind of a matter of
pride and self-respect to try.
And his story is the story of
Washington during this period
and how Washington, even
though the newspaper versions,
what we read about every
day, is divided into extremes
of right and left, with tremendous
vitriol and deteriorating
norms and etiquettes, all
that is true, but I think that
distracts us from the real
story of the last generation,
which is that Washington has
become what it was in the
late 19th century, which is
a pawn of organized money.
- Let's talk about the celebrities,
and I think there are about 10 of them.
And we can say first off
that the only one that
comes off looking really
good is Elizabeth Warren,
we'll put her aside.
- Don't forget Raymond Carver.
- Oh, and Raymond Carver,
the writer, that's correct.
But I want to try to
distinguish them in some way,
to find a common characteristic.
And one thing that struck
me was in the ruins,
and we're talking about the ruins,
each of them found a niche, basically.
And in the case of some who
thought the old institutions
still existed, Colin Powell,
well we know what happened
to him, he was in an administration where
the people didn't really
care about the institution.
- Right, I think two of them,
you're absolutely right.
Two of them were creatures
of the old institutions.
Colin Powell from the military and
essentially government service,
and Robert Rubin from Wall
Street, and the treasury.
They both believed in those
institutions and were leaders
of them, and didn't see the
rot that was setting in.
So that when, in Powell's case,
Bush took the country to war in Iraq.
And when in Rubin's case,
his last job at City Group
as a very well-paid executive.
- 15 million a year.
- 15 million a year, for
doing not all that much.
Became inextricably tied to the practices
that brought the economy down in collapse.
They didn't see it, they
didn't see their own,
that whether or not their
intentions were good,
and I think in both cases they were,
that they had become a
part of something that
not only no longer worked
but that was actually
undermining the larger public interest.
Wall Street and the public
interest parted ways a long
time ago, and I don't think
Robert Rubin ever saw that.
So their stories are a little more,
I would use the word advisedly,
but a little more tragic.
I think the other celebrities in the book,
one thing that's
interesting is a lot of them
come from nowhere, rather like the
characters we've been talking about.
They come from very, Oprah Winfrey
grew up in poverty in Mississippi.
Jay-Z from the housing
projects of Brooklyn.
Sam Walton from a little town in Arkansas
and Oklahoma, in that part of the country.
Newt Gingrich, terrible childhood.
Sort of an angry and hard
stepfather, Gingrich was adopted.
No one in his immediate
family seemed capable
of just loving him, and
he became a hard man.
So they all come up out of
very difficult circumstances,
and they reinvent themselves,
they kind of create
a new way of being an American.
And they, rather than building up
institutions, they break them down.
Gingrich comes into Congress in '78,
the year that the book begins,
and immediately starts throwing rocks
and baiting the speakers of the house,
and really trying to polarize the place.
And to force the democrats
into mistakes that will
lead to a republican takeover,
he's a revolutionary.
Jay-Z comes out of Brooklyn
and very calculatedly
starts selling crack in
order make enough money
to launch a career as a rap star.
And his story is of
meteoric success, but almost
success at all costs, and
as its own justification.
So that breaking the rules
isn't just something you are
allowed to do, but something
you're encouraged to do,
because the old way of
holding down a job and going
to school and putting one
foot in front of the other,
it just doesn't work anymore,
it's a sucker's game.
Sam Walton institutes business
practices that lay waste
to retail establishments
across the heartland,
including in Dean Price's
part of North Carolina,
and turn Americans into
low-wage, low-price consumers
and drive manufacturing,
help to drive it overseas.
So these are all in some
ways empire builders
who are doing it in the ruins of the old
and are partly responsible for
destroying the old institutions.
And that is a new kind of leader
in this country, a new kind of elite.
They're not custodians, they don't have
a sense of a higher national interest.
They have their own interest,
the interest of the empire
that they're building,
and damn the consequences.
- And Walton is extremely
interesting I found because
he starts with a rural model,
cheaper and cheaper prices,
paying employees less and
less, to beat the local rural
and Main Street competition.
- Yeah.
- And then somehow the country
comes to him as it collapses,
in the sense that as we get
more and more inequality,
basically, this model makes
sense, especially when
the products are being
made by the Chinese.
- Right, and Walton and
his defenders say that
Walmart made life cheaper for
people in parts of the country
where it was hard to make a living.
They raised standards of
living by lowering prices.
But you could also say they
lowered standards of living
by lowering wages, by driving
factories out and turning
former factory workers into
part-time store greeters
who made $8 an hour and
worked 20 hours a week.
There's a family in the
Tampa chapters in the book,
the Hartzels, who end up
pretty much dependent on
a job like that just to stay afloat.
And they do all their
shopping where, of course,
at Walmart, even though
they hate the place,
because that has the cheapest prices.
So that in a way, the
depression of the heartland
and the hollowing out of the Main Streets
ends up being good for the company,
because it forces people
to buy products at
the cheapest price possible,
which is at Walmart.
It's a race to the bottom.
- Two other celebrities.
Alice Waters from Berkeley
and Oprah Winford.
- [George] Winfrey.
- Oprah Winfrey, sorry, I'm
excited watching the clock here.
What's kind of interesting
is they unintentionally or
intentionally wind up
responding to different
levels of the society
that's being created.
Alice, with the whole focus
on eating properly and so on,
which you suggest is kind
of an elite sensibility.
And Oprah, sort of reaching
into the heart of people
who are really being hurt by where we are.
- Well, the abiding
theme of this whole book
and of the period it's
about is inequality.
Which is growing every
day, and nothing seems to
arrest it, let alone turn it around.
Even the financial
crisis increased the gap
between the top 1% or 5%
and the rest of the country
so that, one figure that
I mention in the book,
the six surviving Walmart
heirs of Sam Walton
have the wealth of the
bottom 30% of Americans.
Which is about 90 million people,
so it's an incredible level of inequality.
So that everything seems to feed into it,
it's almost, it's like a
gas that you can't escape,
it just creeps into every corner of life.
So in Oprah Winfrey's
case, her story is this
tremendously inspiring
one of a very ambitious,
driven, talented girl from the rock bottom
of society, willing her way to the top,
and becoming the empress of television.
And in doing so, kind of living in a class
unto itself, the class of celebrities.
That's her group, that's
who she's comfortable with.
Her viewers are left behind,
and they sort of are,
in a sense worshiping at
the altar of a goddess
whom they can't hope to touch.
And there's this constant
sense with her that
although the message may be,
if I can do it, you can do it,
the reality is, I did it, and
so you don't have to do it.
You can live through
me, through my success.
Alice Waters I think did
some very valuable things,
as Oprah also did, in
making American conscious of
what we eat, where it comes from,
of reminding us that food
should come from where we live,
and that it should be seasonal,
and that it should not
be full of chemicals.
But that, too, has become a kind of,
I see it as like a way for
a certain class of Americans
almost to keep out the contamination
coming from the bottom, from Walmart.
And although its origins
I think are very positive
and very strong, it's been
turned into a kind of a code,
or even a rigid set of rules
people impose on themselves,
in a way that is intensely,
I think, class-driven,
and that divides Americans
by what they eat,
as everything else divides us
according to our socio-economic level.
When I was growing up everyone
ate the same kind of crappy food.
And today, some people eat
very expensive organic food,
and that's all they're going
to eat, and other people eat
what Dean Price sold when
he was a fast food owner,
which is to say mass
produced hormone fed chicken
that's cooked in deep
fryers in Bojangles'.
So it's like, you can't get away from it.
It's not to blame Alice
Waters, but it has fed into
the sense that Americans
need to wall themselves off
from each other in order
to live a good life.
- You talk, in the first
book we talked about, about
whether you change things
by changing the culture
of changing the structure, you even
quote Orwell about that problem.
Have you come to any
conclusion as a result
of this odyssey in writing this book?
- I think that's still
a perpetual question.
Orwell was writing about
Dickens, and saying,
with Dickens, change of structure
begins with a change of heart.
He was not a Marxist, with
Marx it's the other way around.
I'm basically a moralist,
I basically think
what we need at the beginning
of any social change
is a change of thinking and feeling.
And it might begin with
something as simple as
restoring a sense of shame,
and a respect for limits.
Perhaps we don't need to exercise
the incredible freedom of
choice that we now have
all the time, we don't need
to say everything we think
on the internet, because it might end up
having destructive consequences.
But on the other hand, I
don't have any illusions
that either this can happen
by spontaneous combustion,
or that it can lead to structural change.
'Cause we also need things
in our, in Washington,
on Wall Street, in business,
in the media to change.
Whether it's reviving old
structures or more likely
rebuilding institutions in new ways.
'Cause things never return
to the way they were.
I don't know how that's gonna happen.
I do not claim to be either
a profit or a prescriber.
The book does not have policy
answers, it's a narrative,
and that was a deliberate choice.
I thought, we have
enough books that tell us
what's wrong with America
and how to fix it.
And somehow they're all
both true and not true.
We know what's wrong with America,
we don't know how to fix it.
The answers are never enough.
So instead I wanted to hold up a mirror,
or to at least paint a
portrait, so that we could see
what we are, within the limits
of what one book can do.
And that might be the
beginning of thinking about
how we got here, and how it can change.
- George, I wanna thank you for
taking the time to come here
and discuss the book, it's an
extraordinary book which we
really can't do justice
to in an hour's time.
But thank you very much,
and thank you very much
for joining us for this
Conversation with History.
(upbeat electronic music)